the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay I hope we have that wonderful
valentine day I share are you a story
I always make those reservations and put
some sell my calendar should I put it on
calendar my last slide I give a public
lecture I Boston University
it may turns out my sponsor my cell
phone of a slowly so what's date the
last light so you can imagine how many
people showed up
on this public lecture there was a very
very very interesting in fact a
interesting couple and the beaver city
may lecture and I was talking about the
thermoelectrics
and and after that I had a chat with
them and this her see his wife a she
said oh today's his birthday - birthday
and Valentine's Day and so I was very
pleased okay
so coming back last time we were talking
about a very syrupy of would see the
microscopic energy carriers we say okay
if we look at a molecule what are the
energy how much energy they have what
are the forms of energy and then we see
how many we have particularly we
introduced the boards man factor the
statistics and see what's the average
energy is a KT by C D taken translation
as by example and if you think about the
KT
if it's a molecule you can use the mass
one-half MV square equals kt and you can
actually say the molecular speed is very
high the molecule is moving few hundred
meters per second
except they are doing random motion and
and then we see how how far they travel
that's the mean free pass we estimate
the the air molecule the mean free
passes above the hundred nanometer and
with that we we give a very simple
derivation kinetic picture of the
transport the Fourier law of heat
conduction and at the end we went into
the size effects so if you transport the
car risk you lens is less than the mean
free path or less than the wavelengths
of the mature way you will get say
either classical size effect or quantum
size effect and I now that I went
through the quantum size effect
very kind evening and also that the end
of lecture so hopefully today we can
make that up and in today's lecture I'll
be talking about matures waves and
energy quantization and this is a
chapter two so today and next Monday use
two lectures and we'll go through
quantum mechanics okay so that's
ambition there so what I want you to get
is some basic ideas of appreciation for
the importance of energy quantization
and say you see with this very simple
view you can actually understand a lot
of things so let's start with the way I
said in the last lecture when you have
an interface always because the
interface thickness is the karyesh
condenser to zero so it's always good to
say what are the wave you have
reflashing
other waves so let's
start with the general way right you all
have learned about waves in one form
another what are the most important
characteristics of waves right what are
the basic heuristic else waves you have
face right let's see going even more
basic with amplitude wavelengths
frequency right so basic card it sticks
out waves and then when we think about
the frequency we're thinking about time
domain and when we think about the
wavelength we're thinking about Swiss
domain right so if we say if I have a
wave simple web a sine wave right here
is the pure and in the case of time
domain this period is time in the case
of space domain this is the wave length
right so time here or wavelength and but
we normally do lot night to right time
period we like to talk about frequency
right so can anyone tell me what's the
relation between frequency and time
period mathematics now it's a Fourier
transform right
so if you have purity function into your
food or transform the universe is 2pi
over that period so we have a Pyrrhic
and frequency this is the for real pair
right we of course frequency is a 2pi
over the pure so listening time domain
you're very comfortable with the
frequency right and in space domain we
have wavelengths what's the
corresponding Fourier inverse I'm sorry
we've lumber that's probably a less
familiar you you do use often right so
the wave lumber it--had equals two PI
over lambda it's a fully up here right
and of course when we talk about
frequency there's another frequency we
often use angular frequency right so
Omega is the angular frequency is two pi
nu and correspondingly I have a K equals
two pi I tau or is two PI over lambda
okay this is a free space
yeah ah knew you were I'm sorry okay yes
sorry sorry
now all this has a problem well over tea
and otherwise I might have to buy 2 pi
to buy there
thank you okay but that our space is
more complicated in time right space has
direction so when a wave traveling in
certain direction I can say this is the
wavelength in that specific direction I
have I can have kxkykz
so the here K in general is a wave
vector so it's a KX KY KZ and so we have
wave vector I want to be consistently
using capital so this K is the magnitude
of the wave vector right so now we have
the space we have the time basic
heuristics that characterize a wave it's
a pure density and now we can write the
simplest wave
simple form of a way right the simplest
way of the sine wave will cosign with
constant amplitude right so let's write
a simple way and I'll write use the
general symbol Phi and this could be a
vector it could be back your way think
about acoustic wave is a vector wave the
electromagnetic wave is a vector weight
right so a vector that has an amplitude
and I write a constant amplitude and I
have a time Omega T malice
k times X you can go to say sub T Omega
equal to PI nu K is 2 PI over lambda so
this is a way of traveling in the X
direction and then I have a unit vector
represent this vector when I see the
direction that's the wave traveling the
ration so I have two directioner one is
the wave traveling direction the other
is the wave oscillation direction right
if you think about electromagnetic field
the wave is traveling forward and that
is we know you like to magnetic field is
the transverse wave so you'll actually
feel there's a perpendicular to the wave
traveling direction if you think about
acoustic wave this sound wave is a
longitudinal wave so the wave vector is
a propagating to you and the oscillation
the pressure wave is also in the same
direction longitudinal wave right so I
have two directions and this is I can
associate as polarization of the wave
and this X is the direction the wave
propagation direction this is the field
why is they failed direction right so
this is the simple wave of course a here
is the amplitude and somebody mentioned
a face so face of the wave is what's
inside so Omega t minus KX that's the
face and for a constant phase so a plan
of a certain phase value and if this is
a constant that's a constant phase plan
and you can see this plan is moving at a
DX DT
equals Omega over K from here take a
derivative right so that's the velocity
of the constant phase so this is called
the phase velocity and of course the
most common are relation you're probably
familiar is the light where you have for
a light in vacuum we know frequency
times wavelength is the speed of light
I use a small C or here let's put a
constant and so speed of light and and
this we say Omega equals C K right for
like it's a linear relation between
Omega and K in free space but more
generally either you are say very soon
there is a very complication between
Omega and K in general so Omega and K in
general case could be a very complicated
function of the wave vector and what
that means is in different direction
right the wavelength and frequency have
very complete relations and this is a
particular tool when we go to solids
photons and electrons so that's just
awarded down the street and so here we
talk about phase we talk about a sine
wave here but in mathematical operation
if you take a derivative of sine what do
you get cosine right and that's not that
convenient even though it's a simple
enough a simpler derivative where it
goes to itself is the exponential
function
right so very often rather than
representing away in sine and cosine I'm
going to represent it in exponential
functions so this is a complex
representation that's really for
mathematical convenience and if I use a
complex representation I will write this
wave as I can combine a and Y into a
vector that's the wave oscillation
direction and then I will write
exponential minus I Omega T so I use a
complex Omega T much K times X first to
do 1d okay so if you if you see this
right of course it's easier to take a
derivative of an exponential function
and what I have here really means I can
write this exponent sure back into
cosine sine so I have cosine Omega t
minus K X minus I sine Omega T plus K X
right so I have a real part and an
imagined peak in real life of course the
waves normally is either sine cosine so
the big case you stick to say okay if my
solution if my initial condition my
boundary condition or is for the real
part cosine then at the end after I
solve my problem in this complex
representation my real part solution
is what I'm looking for if you stick to
the imaginary part again you have to
look at your initial your boundary
condition and advise the humidity sign
those constraint you see the imagined
part is your solution so that's the this
complex representation gives you a
mathematical convenience a lot of
comment is if you look at the air I put
a minus sign in the front right that's
just my preference it turns out the even
different book people sometimes uses
positive some use negative and
particularly when you go to read optics
and some book I use the positive some
people use a big here and that could
create a lot of confusion because that
will mean they later on your say there
is the after constant that has a real
party imagined in the front that could
be in a positive or negative sign so
unfortunately that's the case and that's
we we don't have a solution there okay
and the other comment I want to say this
waves are travelling waves right your
last lecture and mention the standing
wave if you play guitar
you'll clamp the two ends that's a
standing wave and here is a wave that
traveling in this case Omega t minus KX
into the positive x-direction if it's a
plus KX that's a way of travelling into
the length of the rushing x-direction
right more generalization are here is a
wave in the X direction but I said a K
is January a vector so if I write a
three dimensional plane wave and the
general form for this way is a let's say
again the polarization direction and
amplitude exponential minus I Omega T
- hey is vector R so this is a the
sympathia plane wave in complex
representation in 3d okay general space
and we mentioned here is a travelling
wave and I can use traveling wave to
construct the standing waves example
let's talk about a thing about standing
wave so I have two opposing travelling
waves same amplitude Y is sine Omega t
minus KX so this is a wave travelling
from to the positive x-direction I have
a posing wave traveling in the lady of
the ration same plus K X right so two
traveling waves now and I superimpose
them together what I get right to add to
sign it's too cool
two signs signs sine cosine right so the
negative power cancel so I will get a 2
a sine Omega T cosine KX right so now
you can see I have our standing wave
because these are my loads when the KX
equals zero it doesn't depend on time so
my zero point is fixed right you play
your guitar you press it
here and then you fix your loads there
okay so this way I can use the standing
wave to construct a traveling wave
construct standing way last comment on
wave what's the energy of the wave
typically so energy wave is typically
proportional to the square right the
square so the energy is typically
proportional to the square of the wave
right the amplitude the higher larger
energy those are the basic heuristics
right so with this let's go to talk
about material wave and that's the we
have to go into the quantum mechanics
and let's talk about how I started so
this is a very interesting history in
science if you look at this is a study
about with the optics right and you
heard the probably Newton optics and of
course they when Newton did the optics
hatred the light at the particles he
didn't think light was a wave and so it
took a lot of time to challenge Newton
and there are Wiggins there are a lot of
people you actually it was established
light is a wave it's not a particle and
the the final time is Maxwell equations
for light right so going from particle
to way and Maxwell equations solidify
the wave nature of light and that seems
to be all settled problem except to say
if you go to look at the history of
physics and there are two problems
people recipes one is black body
radiation
and it was found through experiment that
the this is a wavelength and this is the
emission from black body at different
wavelengths and this is a typical curve
of blackbody radiation and with a
classical R wave my hand at the
classical mechanics of a black body for
light unfortunately the trend that
should be always like this right so that
was a big puzzle for physicists at a
time and the other is all related photon
is a hydrogen absorption spectrum and it
was observed that the absorption happens
at discrete lines and the continuum
mechanics say you should have a
continuous spectrum but to see the
measurement accuracy that's not the case
so to answer this puzzle a lot of people
try and it was plunk that first
introduced a radical concept right and
he's rather than when we talk about
electromagnetic wave right we say the
energy is proportional to M to the
square okay it's a continuum you can
have any M cute right
so what Punk introduced is that you
cannot have any continuous function of
that say amplitude you so your energy is
not a continuous function at an energy
at specific frequency can only be
multiple of this H nu
and this H is the Planck constant is 6
point 6 10 to the minus 34 jar second
right n is an integer and 0 1 2 so the
energy of the light cannot be any value
it has to be multiple of this H nu so
that was a radical concept
discretization of energy and so what
happened was the Einstein with the you
know he was a patent Clerk rather plunks
theory blackbody and he did another
radical proposal and he said this means
that the electromagnetic wave is
granular it's a pot has a particle
characteristics so it came back to a
particular particle has energy and the
momentum so what's the momentum of life
right so you know Einstein has his
famous energy relation MC square right
and a momentum P is a mess
because the light is not a particle that
has mass right so we need to get rid of
the mass and so is the MC so we have M
say is a MC square divided by say that's
the energy energy is a chenille dy by
say so is H over lambda so I start argue
that the momentum of this light quanta
is H or lambda
and now the light has both say this is a
basic quanta has both energy unit each
new animal mentum unit of H over lambda
right so with that he argued that like
she has a party girl
this is granular wave it has both the
wave and the particle right and in fact
if we go to raid iron stamp paper in
1905 the povery for papers and wine is
on relativity the other was on Brownian
motion Brownian motion was his PhD
thesis okay and the time he didn't know
Brownian motion they didn't know there
was a Browning observation he was just
trying to infer the size of atoms
molecules and and then he hypothesis
this energy quanta and I wasn't sure the
other one was about the day this is the
photoelectric effect but I thought this
one is together with the photoelectric
effect okay anybody remember for papers
like only so you for the photoelectric
effect with this together is the web
that there only I get I can only
concentrate maybe you could you go back
to check so with this energy quanta
concept he explained another
experimental observation that's the
photoelectric effect and the
photoelectric effect is when you have
two electrode metal electrode you shine
light onto it you will have a current
flow current flow
okay and the physics is that the light
get a drive electron all over the metal
so go from one electrode to the other
electrode okay but the puzzle was that
you should be the current it should be
proportional to the intensity of light
so the more likely come the higher
currently you have but the experimental
observation is if the light wavelengths
or say frequency right wavelengths is a
too long or frequency is too low it
doesn't have current so there's a
threshold for this photoelectric effect
and our instance explanation is this is
the word electron state right later on
we'll see this is the Fermi level and
here is the it needs to come out of the
metal to the vacuum right and the there
you got a difference in energy and this
difference here is vacuum is the work
function so that's why you see you have
to have you have to have this energy
quanta that's new larger than the work
function and it's likely you get a one
boy you lock out another bull right so
this is the granular the consequence of
this granular picture of light and uh in
fact if you go to check the Einstein
paper so sometimes I joke he's a heat
transfer guy if you go to check I step
favours he really all those argument
were based on uh thermodynamics if you
think about the time there was no
quantum mechanics and they only had the
classical mechanics and the boards man
at the best the boards man cities or
physics that's that was a foundation at
the time and Maxwell equations right so
are very interesting to read those
articles and it took actually on this a
quanta of light
it took instant another ten years or so
to sick more and came up with the idea
of a stimulated emission right that's
also a further see the the the like
artistics okay so with that we have
basically relation plank Einstein
relation the energy of the quanta is H
nu and the momentum of the quanta is H
over lambda and this is a 4 p.m. wave
and later on at a time they didn't give
the name photon so was the unti R 1930s
somebody suggested this basic energy
quanta for life is called the photon
okay
and so that's where I stand
stopped on this photon I said he said
stimulated mission with that and then
there was a graduate student
his name was de Broglie between his PhD
thesis and he looked like this
Planck Einstein relation for the quanta
and there is going from a wave to
particle right and he made a very bold
extrapolation it's a white just for the
electromagnetic wave why is not for any
particle also has the reverse wave
carrot sticks so ah this de Broglie
further extended this to matter waves he
didn't have an equation you couldn't
write as a wave equation but I say I
have to like admit I didn't go to read
his thesis but I heard the deceased was
very short and just to say reverse and
made the argument and then people went
to do the experiment and the experiment
on that was by a division and humor so
okay so if we think about the mature way
right let's take a say the wave lengths
off another is H over P and I can go to
calculate what's the wavelets and I take
any object or one kilogram and move one
meter per second with the wavelength
that's just H you write P is M way it's
1 and we will answer 10 to the minus 34
so I think this is are probably related
to gravitational wave people still
trying to establish a relation between
gravitational waves and the quantum
mechanics orders but that's too short so
your M is too large and basically if you
go to take an electron the electron mass
is 10 to the minus 30 19.1 10 to minus
31 if we electron moves one meter per
second the waving is very long because
the 10 to the minus 34 divided 10 to
minus 31 give you 10 to the minus 3
meter that's a very long wavelength
right
in fact it's too long so uh the Davisson
and Germer experiment was actually
shooting electrons yes ah well say you
should go to ideas you go to
relativistic velocities so when you go
actually electron when you see relative
what do you mean relative to each other
or relative right ah relative to which
observation system what do you mean I
don't know good question
okay so rap to the emitter of the
electron relative to the question is
relative to what was the observer I
think it's also has to be a relative
observer
yeah should be let me see if you think
about Doppler effect right a mobile
object emit and you have different
wavelengths depends on the speed okay
so lambda equals C H over P and what
they did is shoe the electron aluminum
foil so an oomph oil has atoms right and
uh and when you use periodical
arrangement of atoms so when you have a
wave comes in and a waves if your
article structure you have constructive
destructive interference you have
diffraction so they only go to certain
directions so what they observe is they
transmit it if you look at the different
directions and transmit the electron has
spikes at the angle right and that
established the evidence the electrons
of waves okay so all those people got
lottery prize of course and so that's
the this is this in fact is the
foundation for the tools you'll be using
some of you user in research
the typical transmission electron
microscope TM
microscope right so how it works
you one way is you use a very sharp
teeth constant tip you have applied a
voltage between this tip a high voltage
you drive the electron out okay so this
is a field emission when you elect your
voltage applied hi laughs or tip the
electron get enough energy they go
overcome the they jump to the vacuum
okay this is a few mission you can also
heat this tip that's a thermo emission
get the electron out of the tip and then
you apply another high voltage to x-ray
this electron and typically you'll see
TEM people see how good is a team ATM
the typical means how short is the
electron wave length so you actually
want to actually electron to very high
velocity and timbi RTM voltages about
the 100 kV 100 TeV
sokeep kilo kilo volt so that's the
voltage you apply to the electrons and
uh and then you say you got the electron
Fulkerson optics so it's not it's the
electron optics another normal optics
and InFocus electron beam to a very
small spot and you look at the because
the wavelengths depends on the momentum
right so the higher voltage the shorter
wavelength so you can look smaller
structures and you can do transmission
mode look at the reciprocal space this
is the diffraction pattern or you can
look at the real space so this is a TEM
and the other is the SEM scanning
electron microscope right and it's
similar in terms of driving electron out
and
does is say it look at the reflection so
in this case T M is transmission so you
have to sing your sample very sit and
that sickness is a typically mm unstrung
or so so that the electron can go
through this sample you look at the
other side right so that's transmission
and and the SEM is your electron comes
in and you look you look at it reflected
electrons scanning electron so you scan
your laser beam electron beam on the
surface and in that case you don't
actually accelerate the electron 200
typical SEM voltage is about 20 K okay
and 20 K is still pretty high and the
resolution is not as good as a TEM
because the voltage right so this is the
the in terms of all what led to the wave
particle duality and
at this time there are a lot of young
people right
it's if you look at the Heisenberg The
Rock I remember see they were all in the
twenties and develop him took this idea
and developing the quantum fricassee the
description for the quantum mechanics
and so we have Schrodinger Schrodinger
is the older guy but he's younger than
me he was in the 30 35 38 range okay
Schrodinger equation so it turns out
before Schrodinger Heisenberg are
developed matrix description for the way
description of this so matrix based the
quantum mechanics right and the story
was that in one summer school
Schrodinger within a summer school and
learned about the Boyd's idea of mature
wave and somebody say there should be a
wave equation there for this material
way
so Schrodinger wrote the equation the
wave equation for the material wave and
this is the H bar square 2 m and that na
plus operator and this is the wave
function and plus potential times the
wave function equals I h-bar the time
derivative of this wave function
okay so that's the Schrodinger equation
and Schrodinger himself didn't know what
this Phi really mean right and if you
look at it take a yo this is yo is the
potential so you feel have an electron
you have a part of your what's the
potential constraint right and then
let's say if we take all this you you
think this at the temperature that looks
like a heat conduction equation right
the first order time derivative second
order space derivative and heat
conduction is not a wave equation so the
magic came from that I write this I is
negative square root right that's the
imagine number D if you think about any
other equation that has I there are any
other equation in physics that I huh
oiler equation where is the I
okay so this is this is really the what
it has is society see the wave function
is a function of space and time and at
the time
stronger didn't have a right
interpretation and it was born and gave
the right interpretation but this caused
a lot of trouble because the Goron say
this wave function itself is not
observable quantity and it's the precise
times the complex conjugate because
normally if you solve this you'll get an
imaginary number there
what does they measure number minute so
it's a complex conjugate will give you a
real number and of course this will be a
lumber that depends on time and space
right and the interpretation is this is
the probability this is the probability
density function
of sending this party girl I just spaced
our and time T okay
this interpretation caused a lot of
trouble because that means everything is
uncertain is the probability you have
uncertainty and Einstein didn't like it
Einstein never agreed with quantum
mechanics and Schrodinger himself didn't
like it he even regret he wrote this
equation that's what I heard okay but
say this was a really the foundation
that we use now for a lot of things so
if you read the the fight and the debate
although say it was a punk who
discovered the Einstein because I see I
added higher Planck was very big shot in
Germany there's a max function Institute
that's plunk and he was very established
and instant with the patent clerk and a
plunk was the editor for this Anna Anna
awful physics the physic and so when I
stand sandpaper he assured publishes
paper even though I plunked it sells I
didn't quite understand his paper this
relativity right nobody claimed the
understanding and bassy later on is a
the this fight between Einstein the
relativity quantum mechanics people got
very very hot and so ah let me just make
the clarification
this is Laplace operator right so is
whatever if in the Cartesian coordinate
so whatever we had you do the
this is an applause and now since cosine
here is a probability probability
density of Fanny's particle in say
location and time so you have a
localization and in probability at the
end fighting the partner in the space
you consider is 1 right so the
localization for this probability is the
wave function integrated over the height
of the space of the whole domain that
you consider should be 1 and because
it's probability so there is the
expectation value right and it turns out
in quantum mechanics everything is
uncertain the space the momentum the
energy the time everything and you have
to calculate what's the most probable
value and the what today uncertainty
with that associated with this
expectation so we have this actin value
and for any quantity this could be so we
use this one is now a number of expected
expected value of any quantity is
integrated over again the same volume
and the wave function and for that
quantity normal representation is an
operator so this quantity in quantum
mechanics is an operator and so we have
the operator operates say the complex
conjugate a wave function operator
a operator operator and if we function
and times the complex conjugate so
operator operates on the function
following it what does it mean so let's
write the operator for few common
quantities for position it's easy that's
just low more are right and like for
momentum this operator now is the
derivative see the momentum operator is
mass I h-bar gridded right so this is
the gradient operator it's D DX in
cartesian coordinate i and d ey j and d
DZ k right so now if you put it here
this wave function goes here so it's D
psi DX plus n dy that's the operator you
take that derivative and then you do the
complex conjugate you integrate and
that's your expectation value okay and
for energy
that operator is Hamiltonian and they
you can actually think about the
momentum so is the kinetic energy
divided a plastic potential energy so
it's a to M that's a kinetic energy plus
the potential energy and now the P is a
operator so if you do your C IH Square
and this laplace top product give you
all greeting operator product given a
plus so what you have here is the mass H
bar square 2 m Laplace plus the
potential potential is a function is
another gradient so you can just use the
product so you can go back to look I to
the Schrodinger equation here right this
is the kinetic energy potential energy
and that's what we have then okay now
let's look at some the first thing about
the general solution for the Schrodinger
equation I want to get about get the
time dependent term out first so for
that I will soon the energy at the
potential energy is a function of space
only it's not a function of time this is
not always the case for example when I
want to solve a problem light and
interacted with the electron right and
in that case I have a time dependent
potential because light interactor that
the interaction will be time dependent
so but for the moment I want
finder only given potential what's the
energy of the system so I say a space
dependent but time independent potential
and in that case if you go look at your
Schrodinger equation you see here right
this is a time dependent this one is
space this one is space so I can use the
separation of variable to separate the
time and space part so I'm going to
write in this case I'm going say
time-space into a separation of variable
space add time function okay and we
substitute into the equation
so let's say if you substitute into this
equation what you find is a half sigh H
square 2 n dope the Laplace operator the
sine plus you'll plus I equals I h-bar Y
and dy DT so this is the same as we swap
any separation of variable problem this
is space dependent only this is time
dependent only so the only way the equal
to each other is the each of them is a
constant of that separation of variable
so let me use you note that constant Z
it's not that incident I use e because
this is turns out is the energy okay so
this part is easy to solve is the first
order differential equation when I solve
it what I have is y the function of time
is exponential okay so say a constant
times the exponential minus i ii / h
times t right so ii or HD i just use
another notation omega if you think this
is energy but let me move so it's minus
i omega t so that's the time-dependent
ur okay and the space dependent term
once i have the separation of variable
the space dependent term now is you say
here is a multiply this x plus i so what
I have
is a plus
yo minus E Plus I equals zero so this is
a time independent schrodinger equation
and this is the one that you use when
you want to solve say most problem
what's the energy of a matter what's the
energy of electron with the energy alpha
C crystal what are the allowable energy
of atoms of vibration in crystal this is
the Schrodinger equation time the
independent Schrodinger equation and
that the difference of this is if you
look at it
what's differ for each problem is really
this you it's a potential that this
would matter matter wave electrons atoms
right what's the constraint they're
considering by different potential and
this different potential give you
different energy state of the matter
okay a few more comments on this
Schrodinger equation and I said this is
the separation of variable here this is
e and in fact that you can go to show
because we see the energy operator
energy operator where is my energy
operator here
here energy operator is H so it turns
out that the H if you substitute using
what's the expectation value and go to
use the Schrodinger equation you'll find
out that this H expectation value is
actually e I'm not going to go through
all the math but so that separation of
variable constant e represent actually
the energy of the system the log will
quantum energy quantum states and that
the other comment is this equation you
actually use the equation to solve e
right so this is a different then you
solve a heat conduction equation where
you give boundary condition you find the
temperature distribution it's an
eigenvalue problem this is what do you
want to find given boundary condition
given potential you typically have an
eigenvalue allowable value for the ie
that's the quantum constraint give you
see not all the energy of the system I
say any energy but to see the allowable
value a few more comments and because
the wave function is probability right
they so we have basically relation
ah
one is Heisenberg uncertainty principle
you all have heard this so any value has
this spread right expectation and the
standard deviation so if we define the
standard deviation the other q equals
and the typical we define the standard
deviation is disick you
that's the operator remember - the
expectation value square and the
expectation value right that's how we
define standard deviation okay this is
the operator
this expected expected value so a
freedom an expected value and again you
operate on you put in this into your our
expression Omega that's how you
calculate the standard deviation and
what the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle tells you is for example
momentum there's a copper pair momentum
and the space are the two conjugate and
you can never reach your precision that
better than h-bar over 2 H by itself is
H over 2 pi and the same for energy and
time you can never do better than h-bar
over 2 so this is the Heisenberg
uncertainty
and finally after they say we'll go to
solve more Schrodinger equations okay my
final comment is again from Schrodinger
equation we're not proving you can
manipulate the Schrodinger equation and
the way you do it is for example here is
real you multiply common complex
conjugate on both sides and the second
time you take a complex conjugate and
multiply by real and then you take the
difference of the two and what you get
here is like a continuty equation so
what do you have in that case I will get
the square so that's the probability
density right time derivative of that
probability density times a flux term
the divergence of the flux equals zero
so this is like a mass continuity and
this J is your mass flux so the particle
flux for in the quantum term so this is
flux is IH bar 2m complex a the wave
function and we need this expression
later on when we look at what's the
electron reflection other interface
right if you do charge transfer you need
to look at how the interface which
scatter will reflect the electrons and
that's a mature way and will also do
what's the electromagnetic wave
reflection the interface and in fact
later on we'll be starting with two
different equation Maxwell equation for
electromagnetic
and the electron equation for from the
Schrodinger equation and you'll find for
all those waves so they find our
expression of reflectance the very
similar okay so uh any questions here
let me recap it's a lot of material
that's a basic see a lot of sensor so
what we have for amateur wave and it's
come willing at least let's say I like
to use stronger equation there physics
is actually like to they're different
there's three different ways to do
quantum mechanics you can go Heisenberg
that came to matrix representation and
you can go Dirac and this Dirac Adu
operator quantum mechanics and a lot of
physicists book physics books is reading
operator format okay and you go to read
papers with many most of times actually
reading your operator for me I'm not
familiar with their Schrodinger equation
is the master equation here and the wave
function right so it's like kinetic
energy potential energy and time
dependent term right and this is
precisely the wave function it doesn't
have meaning itself it's only true they
complex it the wave function multiply
the complex conjugate that gives you the
probability of finding this matter a
certain space R and time and this
because of that everything in the
quantum world is probability based so
you have best say the expected expected
value you have standard deviation right
so you have the uncertainties and that's
the basic idea we have
I see what do we introduce today and
what I want to do next and promise you
right I say every week I want to go to
look at some journals and then we looked
at last Wednesday and this is the
Wednesday
so what Joyner you want to look you can
ask me questions
well I turn on the projector
I like that idea
so it turns out the simplest solution of
the Schrodinger equation in the past was
a pretty much academic exercise and then
say everybody will take that as your
first solution of Schrodinger equation
because that's a simplest mathematics
now it was the problem I talked in the
last lecture it's a film with standing
wave inside that's 1d right a film so
you have boundary condition and the
energy solution what's the energy
quantization we'll go through that
mathematical next lecture but you have
seen in the last lecture
let's see that's the simplest solution
the energy quantization so in the past
this was really considered just an
academic exercise but that changed in
1970s and that's because people start
well of course people have looked at
some film deposition for four hundred
years right but in 1970 there was this
idea how if you deposit a perfect film
you actually can make quantum Wells you
can see the energy quantization and this
was a by SR Keehan Ritu and they
actually made the super lattices
multi-layer of thin films so it was
suggested who look hi des Applied
Physics Letters I didn't coordinate with
him so that was a suggestion okay and
this Applied Physics Letters and let's
see Richard hi let's look at for your
research highlight I did actually look
like this this morning so what I found
is let's go to the last two of this
research highlight
right so I say here you have to one is
reduced as the improved photo response
in the mass an economist like quantum
dot infrared detectors no you can see
the quantum da the energy quantization
right and the next one is the factory
electron blocking layer on the teaser
electric field in gallium indium gallium
nitrite guard I tried multiple condom
wear so this energy quantization is a
why they explored particular in
photonics field to make better leaders
better detectors and so let's go a
little bit deeper
no this is another the paper is the
actually the paper beneath it that's the
one I should click okay this is the
quantum dot right so what you will see
the energy band diagram that's drawn so
it's a sim films layer right and it
turns out today
the this quantum dye indium arsenide
quantum dot is when they grew those
films so it's through the some electric
MB molecular beam epitaxy and you have a
a heated assail you do ultra high vacuum
you don't want any junk there and this
molecule see the atom were read as a
evaporated and goes to a target at a
controlled rate and when you grew this
indium arsenide film it has a C it's a
crystal normally issue to a film but
because the lattice constant is very
different so they are string okay so
once you grew to a certain thickness
they cannot grow a film anymore the
stress will break them up into dots okay
so that's how people make let's control
the quantum dot and then when they are
very small fuel using here how much is
2.2 mol only Mao is a modern atomic
layer okay and we in that case the dots
maybe just a few nanometers and you have
energy quantization and this has some
examples of an energy band diagram or
learn more and this in solid but
essentially you see this is the energy
diagram let's say last time I say a
partner in I say a standing wave right
so this is the film the standing wave
and those are different energy levels if
it's half wavelength so I say full
wavelengths they're different energy
associated
and with that you can be responsive to
different wavelengths of light
okay so this is a I just this is the one
example and in fact a lot of those very
simple cases you learn in classroom
these these days is being used of course
with with Si complication of real
materials and not the ideal solution
that you say I gave them the board but
say the basic ideas are there and that's
what I'm hoping you take those and you
can don't get afraid that you can start
reading some of this paper and get
familiar with the world not only what
are you doing but what the others are
doing any questions let me just go
through the next one make a few comment
the Lexx one is a golem light right okay
ah what's so special with Ghanim light
right
it's a white band gap and in the past so
column assigned the previous one is a
longer wavelength so the laser semi
cannot laser first you have red gone
master light based and people want to
have green and blue okay and a lot of
people spend a lot of time trying to
develop blue lasers and the first so
they look how the zinc selenide and so
you look at a bank gap we're talking
about bank gap later on okay but say
nobody can make them very successfully
so there was a guy in Japan
his name is a la Kimura and he was not a
PhD he was in this company called I
think it's Nietzsche and they supported
him for long time
the master degree he deposit he was
playing with the garden light right and
he was able to make the leis and say the
immediate light at the blue everybody
was shocked because then nobody was
working on goddamn light right see
people were looking at the links and
light their direct si because it's hard
to grow those so carbon I tried that was
in this 90s and since there people are
like making after device making
electronic device and again say if you
grew very thin films you can have that
energy quantization the condom wells
right in the case of parkour is a dot
it's a quantum dot the film is a will
it's actually a 1d problem 3d problem
okay so we for lecture lecture will
solve the 1d problem okay I'll stop here